hello everybody I hope that you're are
good first of all I want to say thank
you very much for your support on the
YouTube videos on X on telegram
everywhere thank you because it really
makes me want to keep posting more
content so thank you I appreciate your
support and this video is going to be a
bit different basically because it's a
bank holiday Day in the US so of course
if the biggest stock market of the world
is post today is not is not active today
then there is going to be that much
activity no much volatility and the
charts can be a b slower so I'll tell
you what I'm expecting well I'm going to
start telling you but I by saying what I
don't expect to happen I don't expect to
see any more downside pressure today
okay so today I don't think we're want
to see lower prices most likely I'm
expecting some kind of consolidation and
Bing price action but if there is any
volatility today by chance then it
should be to the upside favoring higher
prices all right so that's what I think
now let's talk about the weeks so let me
put in the keator so you can see more
that's the 50 ma the weeks perfect we
talked on Monday's video about this week
and also in the update that week got
filled in yesterday video we talk about
this week we said it's going to get
failed he also got failed and right now
there is no any noticeable weeks in the
chart all right so um I'll tell you on a
scenario that I'm getting prepared for
or in case it happens so you can also
understand what it could happen and how
uh it what it would mean basically if
you start to see Bitcoin consolidating
again inside this Orange Box and you
start to see Wicks to the downside but
price is not progressing any lower and
it's not breaking below this Zone that
is going to mean that the market make it
is ready to be Longs okay that building
longs to higher that doesn't H that
hasn't happened yet for that you still
need Bitcoin to go here and I start to
see more weeks more weeks more weeks
more weeks more weeks for the next days
so it hasn't happened yet it doesn't
mean that's going to happen but it's an
scenario that I want you to to keep in
mind in case it happens okay also from
here we could simply go again to test
the 4 or 50 for example so again it's
not a day really for shorting okay and
also not really a day for trading but
even less for shorting so uh careful
with that right now that's the thing
that I to talk about
Bitcoin I promised you yesterday that
today's video was going to be also about
the altcoin market and the Bitcoin
dominance and stuff so let's do a little
altcoin market update so if you've
noticed what Bitcoin has been doing for
the past two weeks what 12 days really
since the 7th of June Bitcoin has been
in a
downtrend in a lower time frame a
downtrend quite significant because it's
been a 10% drop in in 2 weeks or less
than two weeks quite a
lot and meanwhile the Bitcoin
dominance has been going up because if
you notice this the 7th of June it's in
this area here and since that day the
Bitcoin dominance has gone up basically
3 and a half% okay and that is quite a
lot for the Bitcoin dominance because if
you zoom out you see it's quite slow all
right moving it doesn't it doesn't break
many areas so
I've already talked about this in
previous videos about the altcoin market
updates but when if you want to know
what's going to happen to Alin then you
only have to pay attention to bitcoin
and and to the Bitcoin dominance if the
Bitcoin dominance goes up while Bitcoin
versus the dollar perir in the dollar
perir goes down then alins are going to
really take a a big hit to the downside
and in the other hand if Bitcoin in the
dollar p is going up and the Bitcoin
dominance goes down at the same time
then you can expect a good Alcon rally
so um these are two simple um tips for
you to know if you didn't know them yet
and I'm going to tell you what well
basically hang on hang on hang on let's
check what's happening to the in the
total three chart this is basically the
market cap of altcoin also what of the
whole altcoin market and also the stable
coins so if you notice the seventh of VI
is
here there has been a drop of 18% and
again this is also counting a stable
coins so this is midcap altcoins big cap
altcoins micro cap and a stable coins so
18% including stable coins that is
really then higher for the Alin market
so that's around 24 25% in the ALCO
market so that is a huge drop okay
basically because because Bitcoin has
been going down while the Bitcoin
dominance has been going
up and for us to know what's going to
happen next to the ALCO Market we need
to try to understand what the Bitcoin
dominance and Bitcoin is going to do
next so if if you go to the Bitcoin
dominance
again and we go to the Daily time
frame this is um an idea that I drew two
weeks ago it's playing out but it
doesn't mean that it's going to continue
playing out I'm going to explain why but
basically I was forecasting uh a little
drop first it happened there and then a
recovery of these two liquidity pools
here this one and this one okay the two
liquidity pools have been retraced you
can see there they've been retraced and
now I'm an well my idea anticipates a
drop in the Bitcoin dominance okay it's
no big drop it's basically to go back to
these lows there what a straight line
right
uh a bit better but not great but um
it's too too soon to to call this simply
because I don't know if this is a
support retest of this um yellow
rectangle that used to be resistance now
that could be support so if we start to
see something like this in the next days
that means that it might be getting
ready for a new move up but if we start
to lose this yellow rectangle and
basically we are in this state here that
is when I can start to say okay maybe
this projection is on a play out and I'm
then expecting a drop here to this lows
and that is when the altcoin market can
recover a bit so um a bit too soon to
say but I want you to to see ER this
projection that I only started once on
Twitter when I made it and I didn't
really update much about it because I
think it's too soon to to to to take it
into into consideration
really uh and that is pretty much what I
think of the Alin Market um I think it's
a bit too soon to say and I'm paying
attention to the Bitcoin dominance so if
we lose this jell rectangle then that's
the time for me to to think that we're
going to drop low
okay and see a recovery in the alcohol
market now I want to talk about an
investment that I made yesterday and the
only the only reason why I'm talking
about it is because I want to be
transparent with you and I want you to
know what I'm up to so then you can
maybe do a bit of research see if it's a
good idea and if you also like the idea
or not fine with you but I'm not trying
to make anybody to put money where I put
the money that's not what I'm I'm trying
to do here at all okay I'm just trying
to be transparent with what I'm doing
and I don't know guys if you know that
um there are three artificial
intelligence tokens that are merging
into one like the Pokémons or the
digimons get evolving into a bigger one
uh next month and those are fetch AI top
one artificial intelligence Alon ocean
protocol and Singularity net those three
artificial intelligence tokens they are
merging into one called ASI artificial
artificial super intelligence Alliance I
think it's called and that is going to
happen next month I think in two weeks
and I'm quite hopeful that it's going to
to turn out well okay and I'm going to
explain to you simply why simply because
Nidia has carried the whole stock market
this year has even outperformed Bitcoin
one of the only assets that have been
able to perform Bitcoin is NVIDIA and it
has really carried out the whole economy
of the of the of the US of the stock
market this year it's insane one single
asset and it's been mainly because
they're developments in artificial
intelligence okay also let's not talk
about the microchips are super valuable
and because um there is no much
production also midia this week has
become the most valuable asset in the
stock market by market cap top one he
has beat Microsoft in market cap so
that's huge and if this project ASI is
going to be the top one artificial
intelligence crypto token by Miles
because the market cap is going to be
huge compared to the second project it's
going to be huge and they're going to
have a a big a big team probably with
more ambitious plans and that's probably
why they are merging together because
they already have some plans I imagine
maybe they can do well and they can
compete with bigger companies and do
more developments and then the the price
of the asset can increase okay that's
what I'm hoping
so um I'm going to show you first what
binance says about it this is the
binance official website they're talking
here about the mergin that they are
supporting the mergin blah blah blah and
they're saying here that the first of
binance will theist fed oan and
Singularity tokens okay and is is here
very clearly that the 5th of July that's
in two weeks at 8 a.m. UTC time trading
will open for the ASI pairs of BNB
Bitcoin USD in a spot trading pair so
I'm guessing that this is when they are
doing the mergin okay and that means
that if you have in your wallet any of
these three
tokens then automatically they are going
to become ASI okay so the exchange is
going to do the whole process for you uh
that's what I'm understanding and that
understand that's going to happen the
5th of July although there is no
official date but if binance is listing
the token and it's available to trade in
a spot I suppose that that's when the
mer is happening the 5th of July and now
my question after this was okay how what
the price because if all the alcoy
market has been dropping how much have
these three tokens dropped and which one
is better to buy so let's go back to the
charts I'm trying to to show you my
whole thought process yesterday to to
decide to put whether to put money or
not and which one to buy so what I did
basically was to check the three tokens
ocean protocol and I noticed okay this
has dropped 70% since the highs big drop
and that's happened since the 1st of
April so in
uh two months and a half pretty much 70%
drop so now it's quite a discount at a
cheap price of course it's risky because
it could continue a bit drop continue
dropping a bit lower so if right now
it's at 54 Cent who knows maybe drops to
40 cents can that happen why not okay
here there seems to be some kind of
support around there so why not it could
happen but I think that this price is a
good discount then I check the next one
I went to singularity
Singularity net and this token has
dropped 68% pretty much the same as oan
and the same why not it could continue
dropping lower how much well I don't
know there could be some support perhaps
in this area there okay at 36 Cents can
they get there maybe but the price is
already cheap to me more the other one
fetch let's check it there it is
if you notice all of them have the same
price action okay a long week
consolidation at the 50% and then a drop
to the 100% of the week and even a bit
lower so pretty much the same price
action and feds has dropped also 68% so
they are moving in the same way uh there
has been a big drop in all of them the
price at a discount it could G in
cheaper and I said okay so if I want to
put some money now which one should I
put more money to get in more ASI so it
can I can be more efficient with my
money and then I found this calculator
let me show let me show it to you I
found this website I'm going to leave
the link in the description you can also
use it and it basically tells you how
much ASI you get for your ocean
Singularity net or fetch Ai and I
thought okay if I put
$5,000 and um I'll tell you very quickly
why $5,000 um
basically I could make a whole video
about this but my whole point of making
money through crypto trading is to then
put that money into something safer and
something safer to me is real estate is
something that I am passionate about I
love it I'm learning a lot I'm not bad
at it and it gives me quite a good
amount of money so my goal with crypto
trading is to put money in real estate
okay now if I risk $5,000 and this idea
doesn't work out and it turns out bad
and I lose the $5,000 then it's not an
amount that I am going to be upset about
luckily but if I for example invested
$20,000 and I lost it all then yes I
will be a bit annoyed because with that
money I can literally pay a a deposit
for a loan okay and then I can get a
loan for a new real estate apartment and
then I can put on rent and I start
making money and yeah it will be
annoying to lose another investment okay
so this is how my brain works and this
is something that that's the message
also I want to send in this video that
you have to try to know what your goal
is for what use you want to give your
money and how much risk you are willing
to take like how what's the amount that
you are willing to lose and you are not
going to even ttch about it okay and to
me that's $5,000 basically because
$20,000 is an entry of an apartment
$10,000 is close to it so so if I lost
$5,000 on this that it's a bit risky
because of course this could continue
dropping lower maybe the project doesn't
do well for a year because maybe the
teams don't match well together who
knows anything can happen it's a bit
risky right then $5,000 to me it's a
risk that I can take but at the same
time $5,000 can turn to $25,000 if I if
the project does
H partially well so that's the way I
think okay try to do the same exercise
for yourself and you'll figure out how
much money you're willing to to risk in
any investment that you that you do and
well anyway let's talk about this
calculator very quickly the the
official ex exchange rates are these one
fetch is one ASI one to one pity one oan
and one a what one one ocean and one
Singularity token is 0 to 43 so
here if I buy
$5,000 right now I could buy in Ocean
this amount of ocean which is worth
3,975 ASI when the merging happens if I
put $5,000 into Singularity and get this
amount of tokens of Singularity which is
worth
4,34 ASI you can see that it's higher
than ocean and if I fo fetch is even
worse are going get 3,875 ASI so to me
it's very clear that yesterday if I
click the buy button on Singularity or
or on fetch there is a difference well
literally clicking the buy button on
fetch it cost me
$200 okay and so obviously I clicked the
buy button on
Singularity that's what how I came to
this uh understanding that if I had to
invest into this then it's better at
this moment to to buy Singularity token
for the mergin okay
to get more amounts of tokens so um
that's simply um what I think um maybe
when the token comes out um let's see
how it does maybe I can talk again about
it again this is not Financial advice is
this is not enough at all um I'm just
talking about it because I want to be
transpiring with you about what I invest
in I think it's
something uh honest and let's see how
this goes uh if it does spad then I'll
tell you okay I've lost some money and
if it does well I'll tell you okay it
went well so anyway quite like a
different video thank you so much for
watching guys and I'll see you soon